and speaking of important this is a big
start for tuki toussaint i'm not quite
sure what to make of tuki's big league
season so far for atlanta jeff his first
two starts for the braves were
spectacular his last two were kind of
so-so and then you know what welcome
travis you said 86 games on the open
that he's been out been waiting to get
not just that bat
but the veteran behind the plate and
leadership now you got him and vote you
got two veteran catchers to take you the
refs away no balls two strikes and a q
shot right back to the mound wet
baseball and a flip to first is in time
farmers retired and we're underway with
the ground ball back to the mound
and strike three castianos is retired
two outs first strikeout for tooky
toussaint tonight
and tooky got him to swing and miss he
works around the joey votto single
winker can't score on a single to center
and the braves shut him down no score
21 starts on the year this year for wade
miley 270 in his major league career
that finds him 94 wins against 89 losses
as ozzie albe steps into the right-hand
banners box
he greets him with a lead off two strike
single
know how ozzie loves hitting against
lefties and that's a good sign jeff
getting some hits from him out of that
number one spot on the lineup guard
and solaire takes highway miley with a
walk that's rare riley 26 rbis since the
all-star game
line drive smoke to center
but make way can't get it it's off his
club relay race here comes zombies
around third he's gonna score solaire's
coming here's the throw it is gonna be
in time
the braves get a run albie's comes home
to score to make it one nothing
cincinnati with a perfect relay play
erases solaire at the plate
now adam duvall is up
and another walk
that is two for miley and travis darnold
will have a chance to swing the bat in
the big leagues for the first time since
may 1st nick green this is a day that
brian snitker and everybody in braves
country has eagerly anticipated
line drive well hit to right but
castellanos is there and darneau is
retired for out number one in the second
inning that sounded good off the bat
braves getting some good hacks well that
was a pretty swing
so here's the radio
swing and a drive bell to deep left it's
three to nothing oh baby was that smoked
his fifth home run i didn't know he
could hit a ball like that
i mean that ball is absolutely smashed
as miley swings and misses didn't get
that and tooky toussaint has his third
strikeout that's five in a row retired
by the braves righty
farmer a little pop long run freddie
over the shoulder try and he makes the
basket catch beautifully done and
farmers retire two outs six straight for
toussaint freddie might have been a good
tight end if he played football he makes
that catch all the time good pitch
there's that two-seamer chip ran it
right in on him farmers having a great
year
especially in the second half bottle
will step to the plate one swing of the
bat and we can have ourselves a tie ball
game
and he misses with a fastball to load
the bases so it'll be mike moustakas
faces juice runners lead there they go
the pitch is popped up
foul ground freddie freeman has plenty
of room he's got it and tooky gets out
of it mustache pops up with the bases
loaded still three nothing atlanta and
freddy's coming up
patented freddy freeman with that
approach
base hit to left
thought about two but he'll
slam on the brakes lead off single
swing and another rocket this one headed
for the corner
freddie around second on his way to
third ball dies at the wall they're
going to wave him freddie around third
here comes farmer's throw it is going to
be
in time oh i don't know about that one
freeman looked like he might have gotten
the foot down
barnhart the tag let's see if the braves
take a look the tag looked like it was
on the hip
greg gibson rung him up for out number
one
they're gonna take a look
yeah he's safe
give riley an rbi
four-nothing atlanta runner at third no
one out three balls two strikes
poke to right field castiano's coming on
he makes a sliding grab riley tags here
comes the throw he belly flops in safely
and gives swanson an rbi his 60th
castianos leading off the red six
castillano spins out of the way
breaking ball that doesn't quite bend
castellano saying perhaps it got him
well it's reviewable and that's what
they're going to do
oh yeah
that's the easiest hit by pitch you can
have castillanos gets first base reds
could sure use the base runner joey
votto's been aboard twice he is singled
and walked his walk last time up tied ty
cobb for 53rd all time at
walks bono drills it to center field
into the batter's eye
joey
vato
still
bangs
his 24th of the year
and then bruce to castellanos pays
handsome dividends
five to two and you hit that sweet spot
right there to dead el centro hold that
pose
with last time
that takes a bounce it gets past all
bees and riley and naquin never stops
nobody's at second base so he'll gladly
take it not one but two high hops on the
same ground ball you don't see that very
often here's suarez
hey eugeo suarez first pitch drilled to
center field off the wall and overrun by
irania they quit around third he scores
an rvi double hey eugenio suarez draws
the reds within two
blasts at least off the wall out there
suarez gets one up and in
and if you're pulling off the ball at
all that's a picture you can get
now nick castiano's if he could reach
vato would come to the plate
representing the tying run
did that get him again
second time
he is reluctantly hit by pitch well that
time greg gibson believed him right away
so the tying run bats and it's the
smoldering hot joey bottom
bottle
to right foul
the legend grows and it's five five
i mean waited no time at all first pitch
not all that bad of a pitch a little
breaking ball down
from the left-hander smith and just
golfed right out of here
wow
but now you deal with adrianza who's
been tough in a pinch and now darno 90
feet away anything in the dirt you got
to see if barnhart can block it
[Music]
struck him out
fastball by him and michael lorenzen
forces free baseball as we shoot to
extras in atlanta
tied at five apiece aquino trying to
bring home the go ahead run
hard hit ball dansby slides makes the
play
and preserves the tie
wow great play by dansby swanson hard
hit ball rodriguez loving that now again
the braves a chance to walk it off
[Applause]
free runner for the reds aristides
aquino atlanta's own kyle farmer he's in
the lead-off spot
farmer gets it through to right field
windmill on for aquino he scores
kyle farmer
who went to high school just 10 minutes
from this ballpark gives the reds their
first lead of the game it's 6-5 in the
11.
first and second two outs now ozzy last
time just missed
[Music]
[Applause]
the calendar games
the braves blew a five-nothing lead
they come all the way back down to their
last stop with all of their extra inning
struggles
and ozzy albees has hit a game-winning
home run
with the dodgers beating the phillies
late in that game the braves with that
mighty blow
might have just earned a share of first
in the east
you